welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition in this video were
breaking down episode 6 of The Outsider
after the fifth episode was released
early it feels like so long since we got
another entry in the show but the latest
one definitely doesn't disappoint it
finally pulls all of the pieces together
and ends on a big cliffhanger that
teases what could be coming down the
line throughout this video we're gonna
be recapping the entire thing and giving
our thoughts on it and it's ending there
will be heavy spoilers here so if you
don't want anything potentially ruined
then I highly recommend that you turn
off now make sure you subscribe to the
channel for breakdowns of the outside
every week and without the way I just
want to give a huge thank you for
clicking the video now let's get into
our breakdown of episode six
okay so episode six very much centers
around the titular character wishing to
put an end to the investigation by any
means necessary
last week Holly deduced that the monster
currently living in Cherokee City fed on
grief and with Ralph's getting rid of
the loss of his son from his mind he's
now free of its trappings the episode
opens with Holly wanting to go see ralph
about what she's concluded as Arthur
Conan Doyle had Sherlock Holmes state
once you eliminate the impossible
whatever remains no matter how
improbable must be the truth
Holly has ruled out pretty much
everything leaving only one possible
outcome we see a news report showcasing
the death of Tracy Powell last week we
learned was complicit in the outsiders
operation at the town the fingerprints
of the two girls that Heath was accused
of killing are found in Tracy's car
which puts him in the position of being
an accomplice Powell helped her friend
the nurse Heath Hofstetter and then had
himself killed in a shootout due to the
guilt which he was unable to live with
we learn in the episode that he and
Heath were first cousins and it becomes
clear that Elle cuoco chooses people who
can work and move closely with the
person that they are mimicking Powell's
gun was unloaded as we know and he did
go to Hofstede his house in order to try
and get some form of redemption Powell
did say that the outsider had screwed
both him and Hofstadter over and is
likely that he will do the same to Jack
who plays a big role in this episode
while he gets a bus across the country
because of Karl
down last time and she notices the boils
and scarring on the back of Tracy's neck
in a photograph she too has a vision of
the character who tells her to look out
the front window
believing that the bus is crashing she
runs to the front screaming but it's
revealed that it's all in a head this
actually almost causes the bus to crash
itself and it gives the notion that if
the characters get in the way there
could be worse consequences for them
than what was originally going to happen
once more it shows that the outsider is
able to terrorize targets in their
dreams and make them see things and
visions this has happened to several
characters in the run so far including
Jessa Kahn's and of course Ralph's wife
Jeannie it is possible at Ralph's
version of a son was a manifestation of
the outsider but personally I believe it
was actually a son as it left a hopeful
message rather than the one of do not
the outsider tends to bring Ralph does
question this in the episode but that's
just how I took it
it keeps sending these visions because
it wants the investigation to end
they're all costs and similar to penny
wise it is able to manipulate people
into leaving it alone this was a big
part of the book it in which the killer
Klown would mentally manipulate the
police into not looking further into the
disappearances of children and it's
clear the outsider moves in a similar
manner while sits putting big roadblocks
in the way the biggest one actually
comes in the form of Ralph who refuses
to believe that anything supernatural is
going on similar to the source material
he is the most difficult to convince and
exemplifies how the outsider has managed
to carry out its crimes for so long
often people leading the investigation
won't believe what's going on and this
is showcased here Jeanne protests at the
drawing cement that Jessa's story is
true and she comes along to the big
meeting to see Holly's theory now I feel
like I have to make a correction to a
theory from last time if you checked out
our prior video then you'll know we
noticed that Jax sideburn lens changed
throughout the episode and this led us
to believe that the outsider had taken
on his appearance and left the real one
in the woods screaming at trees it looks
like this was just a continuity error as
the jack we see in this entry no longer
has his mutton chops I even went back
through the season to check how they
appear from time to time and yeah it
looks like they just messed up the
length
that doesn't mean that the outsider
isn't slowly turning into jack but I
think that the more likely conclusion is
it is in fact turning into the strip
club bouncer el Coco is clearly closing
in on him and we learned that he's on
parole as well this would make him easy
to frame as those with a criminal past
often look more suspicious also I have
seen some people saying that this
drawing is Jack but it is more like
Terry to me due to the hair which as we
see disappears as the creatures face
does we know in the case of Terry that
the outsider often cuts people to take
their DNA and then use it to transform
into them and as this happened with the
bouncer early on and not in the case of
Jack it is more likely that this is
what's going on the outsider tends to
pick its targets early due to the time
it takes to transform and as the bouncer
was caught all the way back in episode 1
a definitely thing that that's what's
going on Jessa describes the outsider
once more - newly formed professional
sketch artist genie who once again comes
to the same conclusion I kind of feel
like at some points the series is
dragging its feet a bit and I don't know
how many times we can go through this
with the younger girl as it seems to put
forward the same conclusion every time
Jack goes and picks up Ollie and tries
to get to the bottom of what she's
discovered but she rebuffs his request
after realizing something seems off
about him we learn that Jack's wife
walked out on him months ago and though
he says it was the happiest day of his
life his body language says otherwise as
we know the monster el cuoco feeds on
grief and despair and it could be that I
pick Jack as a target in helping it move
because he's just been through a massive
amount of trauma
he writes stop her in the black ooze
that has become a calling card of the
character but whether Jack actually does
this a narc remains to be seen after a
therapy session Holly presents all of
the evidence with the group and draws
the lines between everything I wasn't
invited to the meeting but here's what I
put together in terms of a timeline so
far al cuoco moved to New York and
murdered a child in the form of Maria he
then noticed he'd asked her out and
decided to meet him the next day for a
date after the two got it on and then
took his appearance and followed him
across the country where it met his
cousin and used him to help collect the
two girls both then pinned the murders
on
and it took Terry's DNA and then
followed him in the Maitland's across
America and settled in Cherokee where a
kill Frankie Pearson and friend Terry
Hawley presents a pretty tight case but
glory completely uses it again and feels
like everyone is wasted their time going
down this route that sounds like a
Stephen King novel
Ralph mirrors this - unable to believe
that the apparent best investigator they
could get has deduced that it's the
boogeyman every culture has its own
version of Al cuoco and when creating
the book King actually wanted to show
how legends will perhaps form from our
own superstition I mentioned several
times how King vu Ted Bundy is a vampire
due to his ability to appear like a
normal human on the outside that it is
need for flash underneath what this
episode does is that it says our legends
have their basis in reality
Vlad Tepes the real-life tyrant that
stoic countless people would go on to
inspire Dracula and it is possible at a
lot of our legends such as vampires
witches and werewolves come from people
are acted this way and eventually became
folklore but this series does is that it
takes that notion which we know laugh at
would say is that in Israel and that
these creatures do exist and have for
centuries Jack gets more messages this
time almost in the form of a stigmata
and has a fight with his mother this is
a clear call back to the source material
in which the characters parent died of
cancer knowing that he is scared the
same thing will happen to him the
outsider actually gives Jack cancer and
asks him to kill Ralph in exchange for
ridding him of it it's creepy as hell
and also kind of unintentionally funny
and no wonder the guy's so messed up
we do see that it's all in his head as
the attacks happened without her in the
room at one point and now something that
the outsider is bringing back the dead
it really is just psychically
manipulating them we also learned that
the outsider takes 27 days to transform
this once more mirrors Pennywise who
took 27 years of hibernation between its
attacks the outsider sheds its skin like
a snake and is also lip service paid to
the fact that it may not even be of this
world this could actually cement that
the character may be from another planet
or dimension similar to penny wise who
landed on earth and then began feeding
on us I know you're rolling your eyes
right now
they roll their eyes at Holly - Ralph
flat-out won't believe that al cuoco
exists until Holly does a new trick that
I'm gonna be doing with my iphone to see
if my wife's had anyone over this shows
that al cuoco was in the house and did
horn Jeannie the metamorphosis leaves al
cuoco in a vulnerable state and this is
why it requires a helper it's also
during this time that it sends out radio
wave like messages to disturb people
into leaving it alone while it recovers
gory calls Ralph's over and says out
loud that she thinks Terry may have even
killed the child clearly she feels like
she's betrayed her deceased husband and
it's one of the best acted scenes in the
series so far in my opinion this shows
that al cuoco has been able to convince
those close to suspects for centuries
that they carried it out as the truth
seemed so unbelievable we joined Jack
whose neck looks like mac and cheese and
he lures Holly out to the barn where
Terry's clothes were found the character
has had one of the worst nights of his
life and he looks like how I feel making
these videos he promises her some solid
evidence and tells her not to tell the
Andersons also I don't know why Holly
doesn't instantly look at his face and
figure out something is up but she goes
to the barn anyway
along the way she sees the rash in his
neck and knows that she's in trouble
with nowhere to go
Jack grabs the wheel and forces her in
the direction of the barn what happens
next well Holly isn't killed by Jack if
that's what you want to know and now
that he's exposed himself the net is
closing in with this being carried out
by the character it confirms Holly's
theories that Ikuko is behind it all and
from the preview next week it looks like
the two are talking about the Beast and
why has taken Jack now there is gonna be
some spoilers for the book here so if
you don't want to know anything at all
as I know a lot of you just want to go
into the episodes as blank as possible
then thanks for sticking with the video
this fall and hopefully I'll see you
next week in the source material Jack
actually gets a rifle and at a sniper
location tries to shoot Ralph as he
descends on up cuccos hideout here
though I think they're gonna switch it
up a bit and have this shootout take
place at the barn in the trailer for
next week Ralph says that he knows that
Jack has taken Holly and I think that
this standoff will happen at the barn
with Holly being a hostage he'll cuoco
as we know is out in the woods
and it's unlikely that it would be
hiding at the barn waiting for Holly it
also looks like Jack may be the one to
end his own life as he puts a gun in his
mouth at one point this of course
marries Tracy and he sort of did set
this up in the prior episode I don't
think you'll get the chance though and I
think this shot is just something
significant of his pain rather than how
he goes out overall the episode was a
great watch and I'm really glad they're
finally pulling it all together I feel
like it's ramping up and who knows if
the outsider loses jack is an i in the
next episode and may be forced to step
forward and reveal itself
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts in episode 6 and what you've
thought of the season so far comment
below and let me know and if you enjoyed
this video then please give it a thumbs
up and make sure you check out our big
video yesterday in which you would go
over the insane details we noticed an
Avengers end game after binge watching
the MCU
so one of the best I've ever done so
please give it a watch after this if you
want to support the channel from as
little as 99 cents a month then please
click the join button below your access
to content early and we massively
appreciate it as goes a long way to
helping videos like this get made
if you want to come chat to us after the
show either follow us at definition
whitey I'll click the discord link in
the description below every month we
give away free movies to people who are
subscribed to the channel and this Monty
can win dr. sleep and all you have to do
is comment on a video and make sure you
subscribe with notifications on the more
videos you comment on the more you have
a chance of winning so make sure you get
involved the winners gonna be chosen at
random on the 15th of February and the
selby shipped out from them to ever get
surprise so best of luck that every only
takes part this is the channel for
people who are never missing television
so if that's the kind of thing you like
you need to subscribe to definition
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this you've been the best and I'll
see you next time take care peace